tu as du drapeau comme d'habitude vous
êtes et dizaines de milliers bravo
plus de cent mille personnes dans la rue
ce samedi après midi en france malgré
les restrictions sanitaires et des taux
d'infection que 8,19 records ces
derniers jours dont dix-huit mille à
paris malgré la pluie les opposants au
passeport finale ont battu le pavé
encore plus nombreux que ces dernières
semaines parmi eux les gilet jaune s'en
sont pris comme d'habitude à halle
emmanuel macron plus on avance dans le
temps est en fait plus on nous prive de
liberté moi ça fait deux ans que je suis
en télétravail et bah c'est long et ça
suffit ça a choqué une bonne partie de
la france
qu'un président en fonction en mer d'une
partie de la population
et qu'il ira jusqu'au bout bien sûr mais
qu'il ira jusqu'au bout cabano le
message qu'on va lui faire passer c'est
que nous aussi on ira jusqu'au bout et
que nous aussi on va continuer à
emmerder et c'est ça la stratégie à
paris notamment deux cortèges se sont
élancés dans l'après midi l'un était
emmenée par florian philippot et son
parti des patriotes l'autre
majoritairement composées d'antimatière
et de gilet jaune le mot d'ordre est l
opposition au pass vaccinale dans un
contexte où l'assemblée nationale a
adopté en première lecture ce jeudi le
projet de loi instaurant se passe
d'autres revendications plus anciennes
sont ressortis par miss des gilet jaune
est vraiment le pouvoir qui est en train
de mettre une pression contre les
opposants politiques et nous ici vous
avez des gens pour rien à gagner dans
cette lutte en termes financiers en
termes de postes on est là vraiment
parce qu'on est content ce gouvernement
n'a rien à gagner et en et l'opposition
les gilet jaune et citoyens en colère et
on est toujours là
des manifestations dans le calme parsemé
de légère altercation à paris
[Musique]
ou encore à toulouse où les policiers
ont fait usage de gaz lacrymogènes
[Applaudissements]
d'après le ministère de l'intérieur
trente quatre personnes au total ont été
interpellées dans le pays des milliers
de français donc mobilisés à travers
tout l'hexagone dans l'espoir de fait
reculer le gouvernement sur le pass
vaccinale un mouvement de colère attisée
cette semaine par les propos d' emmanuel
macron sur les non vaccinés